so in the spoon 54 Baker take to a
market and rolling curious curious
curious and action
[Music]
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
lost
[Music]
have been every voice ever heard inside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe forever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the horse brought together
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
a few things and then we'll start saying
alright you know you just you know I
only do didn't know you I don't know
what is the one I mean I guess I'll see
when I'm what is it like is it actually
connected to some issue just hold
anything okay and it's funny it's very
continuing what are they exactly you're
in the middle of it or whatever and then
and we sort of catch you in it and we
get it and then at the end if you just
just tighten the line up a little bit
coming up close it is gays will you come
forward just a hair please
Oh better thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
some was it means family the emotion of
it all
making a film with people that you
really love
and this is the last one like it's crazy
we do nursery pill taking one last look
as my friend the feeling onset is one of
joy I've really liked with this film
that we get a lot more safe together
especially myself Oscar and Daisy the
dynamic between us three is capturing
some of that spirit of the original
salami
it feels like kids going on an adventure
right and then it was fun too because I
hadn't properly worked with Oscar before
and he and John here Larry yes that's my
boy hey we could be a bit cheeky
sometimes as long as he's right next to
me I could do anything
the Star Wars universe has created
friendships that have lasted for 40 plus
years fallen deeply deeply led with his
men sort of capture that spirit and
bring it to a conclusion has been such
an amazing task felt nice to stand there
with Daisy and Austar kind of like whoa
wow that this is truly the end of our
contribution to dishonor but the legacy
will carry on
you